[Music]
we know you probably grew up watching
Disney movies and singing all of the
songs but some Disney songs are super
dark stay tuned to see which songs are
actually pretty racist new around here
don't forget to give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to the things
for more great content now on to 10 dark
secrets about Disney songs they don't
want you to know can you feel the love
tonight let's start this list off on a
somewhat innocent note Simba and Nala
meet again after years of separation
which turns into possibly their most
romantic story in Disney history can you
feel the love tonight at first listen
just sounds like a soft ballad but pay
attention to the song paired with the
video and it'll have a whole new meeting
they are consenting adults that have
known each other since they were kids
but still it's a little weird to think
of your favorite Disney characters in a
mature way we aren't mad at Nala we are
actually impressed
she gave Simba dirty eyes to let him
know they were not children anymore
whatever the case may be
both Nala and Simba were ready to risk
it all whoever added this team knew what
they were suggesting Simba later met
with Nala again and even Timon and
Pumbaa expect the trio to be a thing of
the past
team own even said he'll fall in love
tonight and what else could that even
mean besides Simba losing his v card
this is an actual inappropriate seeing
people her paws are literally in the air
whoo you're just the messenger I don't
even think you have to be an adult to
catch this blatant flirty energy you
probably realized when you were five
that something was different with that
love scene the movie should have
probably rated it PG a whole new world
another innuendo driven romantic songs
from Disney that involves losing the
virginity is a whole new world if you
didn't catch the lyrics being about
intercourse maybe give it another listen
and see how it suggests exploring new
territory you don't want to go for a
ride dear this comes in at number nine
only because of jasmine has she never
heard of stranger danger she didn't know
this man and was ready to ride his magic
carpet and it didn't help that he ended
up being a liar but we guess all is fair
in the name of love let's all just
assume that the magic carpet is some
thing else if you read any reviews of
the song they all suggest that the magic
carpet is actually a metaphor for
something else when Jasmine hesitates to
get on the carpet with Aladdin he
responds by asking if she trusts him
which is a typical boy line
he then boasts about showing her a whole
new world if she lets him a world he
doesn't even know so the blind leading
the blind consider these quotes don't
you dare close your eyes indescribable
feelings hold your breath it gets better
every moment gets better this is clearly
implying that Aladdin was leading her
into uncharted territory Katrina now we
had to reach a little ways back for this
one
all the way back to 1947 to critique
this song in The Adventures of Ichabod
and mr. toad this old reference that
proves that Disney songs have been dirty
since pretty much the beginning of time
is it a more modern term yes but
certainly not a new concept Katrina is a
song by Bing Crosby that is very well
arranged with a message to the young
girls watching this Disney film it takes
a while to get to these lyrics because
they are toward the end but when you get
there you'll hear him stay but Katrina
will kiss and run to her a romance is
fun with always another one to start
yikes some would say this song was
actually discouraging promiscuity
Katrina was always bopping to the next
guy to kiss which obviously in the 40s
was something that was looked down upon
but honestly what's wrong with weighing
your options to us it honestly seems
like the smart thing to do it's kind of
like the 40s version of Drake's hotline
bling' another man crying about the way
a woman lives her life without him
not like Cosby was a saint anyway a girl
worth fighting for
Newland is thought of as one of the most
powerful Disney female characters in a
film that is not exempt the film from
having some ill-conceived notions about
which women are considered desirable so
a few of the songs on this album of
rediff sexism and colorism
including a girl worth fighting for at
first listen the song can be a cute
comedic and romantic war song as the
song continues you hear the men describe
what traits the women need to have in
order for the soldiers to fight for them
let's dissect I want her paler than the
moon excuse us sir but your colorism is
showing but I guess everyone has a
preference right wrong
and fetishizing paleness is just weird
it all depends on what she cooks like is
another line in the song that further
reinforces that women belong in the
kitchen narrative in the song Milan
offers some progressive traits to see
how the men feel about the strong smart
woman what about a girl who's got a
brain who always speaks her mind but the
men definitely weren't feeling it why
are men like this could they be any more
patronizing now we know that cultures
rely heavily on tradition but seeing how
men view women can do some harm to both
boys and girls if girls start to believe
that they are able to do what men can do
and then watch this film and have men
only classify them as desirable if they
can cook thin young girls are going to
be very confused and is it so bad for a
man to have a woman who can speak for
herself I'll make a man out of you let's
just keep move on in the conversation
shall we the next problematic song stems
from the infamous classic I'll make a
man out of you which without contacts
could definitely go for a song about a
boy coming of age in a pretty
inappropriate way but for these purposes
we'll just examine how the lyrics assume
a woman cannot be as tough as a man
without special training from a man in
Milan's case this is a direct form of
hyper masculinity for both Milan and for
the men in training as well the reason
for them even being in training is so
they can toughen up comparing their
beginning weak stages to those of a
woman let's get into these lyrics for a
better understanding did they send me
daughters when I asked for sons you're
the saddest bunch I've ever met the song
is just not okay it depicts girls as
weak and undesirable when it comes time
to fighting it sends the message that in
order to be a soldier just don't be a
girl and we can shape you up to be
strong and tough I knew there was
something wrong with you
of what money luckily this narrative
changes when Mulan ends up saving China
but the song is honestly to catch you to
have this demeaning message attached to
it girls can be strong and for God's
sake boys can be sensitive mother knows
best now we get to the song mother knows
best in most cases this is very true but
in Rapunzel's case not so much her
mother locks her in a tower and refuses
to let her see the outside world don't
ever ask to leave this tower again
Rapunzel and her mother did not have a
healthy relationship obviously but for
this to be an up-tempo song about your
mother being abusive and you being
appreciative would not be a good look
there are actually children with abusive
mothers Disney who knows what watching
this movie could do to them this song
also shows some of the abusive tactics
parents mainly mothers will go to in
order to be in control don't forget it
you'll regret it
mother knows best what exactly which she
regrets thinking for herself this is a
scare tactic that is not always
beneficial getting kind of chubby
I'm just saying cuz I love you is
another line that is so rude it's
ridiculous
it's also insane to have someone locked
up in doors all day long but no one
really mentions that we know that Disney
is a fan favorite of most people then
how did no one object to this storyline
this is sensationalized abuse and yet we
watch it every time we turn tangled on
it's got to stop somewhere under the sea
are you ready to dabble in a little
racism let's start with a little
mermaids
under the sea Sebastian's awful take on
a Jamaican accent could honestly stand
alone but that's not why we're here
today we are here to focus on the black
fish are there black fish under the sea
of course this fish in particular
resembles a certain kind of face that
should never be in any movie but
especially not one for kids the fish is
an underwater version of a blackface
caricature sebastian sings the blackfish
is in as you felt out a strong sound and
if you think we're being overly
sensitive there's actually a petition to
get the blackfish out of the film might
we add that Sebastian also says on land
they were called a why would he want to
do that when he can stay under the sea
and do nothing but float hinting
at the lazy stereotype attached to black
people it's just kind of gross that
Disney would put something like that in
a film and what's even more annoying is
that parents didn't say anything when I
see an elephant fly let's just start
this off by noticing the black crows
singing in broken English while smoking
jive talking if you will I'd be done
seeing about everything when I see an
elephant fly that's offensive Disney but
this is not even the worst part
the main crow goes by Jim Crow named
ironically after the racial segregation
laws why the Disney name a bird after
such horrible laws and why did no one
say anything doesn't this strike you as
weird and that's not the worst part get
ready for this the actors that voice
these beloved characters are all white
talking and singing in their best black
interpretation you heard that right the
classic film Dumbo turned out to just be
one big minstrel show
for those of you who don't know because
African American history was not a
required course in your school a
minstrel show is a form of entertainment
between song and dance by white actors
in blackface Dumbo fans will defend the
classic portraying racial stereotypes by
saying the crows were nice and the only
ones who helped Dumbo but it doesn't
change the fact that the depiction of
the crows in itself is just as tasteful
what makes the red man red the song what
makes the red man red is a prime example
of an inappropriate song the Peter Pan
film came out in the 50s a time where it
was not awful for a fat kid in a bear
costume to ask these kinds of questions
[Music]
not only do Disney have this question
asked in the film but there is a whole
musical number about it what answer do
they give to these children you ask the
red man is red because a girl made the
Native American Prince blush after he
kissed her this could not be more
innocent and far from the truth like
everything else in this world Peter
Pan's depiction of Native Americans is
not correct at all Disney has made this
film to portray Indians through the eyes
of a kid it is not innocent
or cute to foster depict the way Native
Americans were treated in earlier times
the main characters also refer to
Indians as [ __ ] Indians yes this
is offensive lastly let's address the
fact that the native language of the
Indians in the movie is rude
- gibberish Peter Pan is a film that
glorifies the stereotypes of Indians
making them caricatures in the film it's
really sad that this movie was so
popular when it came out
zip-a-dee-doo-dah our last is new song
with a pretty dark message comes from a
film that has been locked away in the
Disney Vault and will never be breve at
least that alone is what secured at the
number one spot the fact that song of
the south lays claim to one of the most
notable songs in Disney history is a
real shame when you think of it in its
correct context the movie is about a
young boy who goes to live in the south
following his parents separation this is
where he meets Uncle Remus I do like the
longer we used to go along with you and
all you need to know about him is that
he is a happy slave the song embellishes
the life he lives as a slave sending the
message out that slavery is not as bad
as history makes it seem while this idea
of slavery was widely accepted when the
movie came out the majority of America's
views have changed our thinking is more
modern at the time when the film was
created these ideals probably aligned
with the creators and Disney doesn't
need that kind of representation
attached to their name anymore which is
why it will never be released again but
then again that's probably for the best
that's it for 10 dark secrets about
Disney songs they don't want you to know
were you surprised by some of the things
on this list let us know in the comments
thanks for watching
[Music]